we're going to be supporting state
efforts we're going to be working with
them to make sure that those great
retailers which are CVS and Target and
Walgreens and Walmart that are opening
their parking lots for drive-through
centers are included but the American
people can be confident that now that we
have the commercial labs around the
country with those high-speed automated
tests you're literally going to see tens
of thousands of tests in the days and
weeks ahead for the American people all
right let's bring in Seema Verma now
that's the vice president I'd say it's
last night with Shawn he's administrator
of the Centers for Medicare and Medicaid
Services and member of the White House
coronavirus task force Simo it was great
to see you and let me ask I was a little
surprised and kind of hardened by the
fact that you guys are expanding you're
gonna have telemedicine for our seniors
tell us how this will work well that's
right the president made a very
important announcement yesterday that we
are expanding telehealth services to our
seniors in the Medicare program so
that's about 62 million Americans and
this is really important because last
week or actually just earlier this week
the White House has been pushing out
information 15 days to slow the spread
of the virus and we've given
recommendations for the American public
about the measures that they can take to
prevent the spread of the virus and part
of that is avoiding you know situations
where there's more than 10 people
staying at home and this is especially
important for America's seniors that
have underlying health conditions with
telehealth they can now get to see their
doctor talk to their doctor and they can
do that from the safety of their home in
the past Medicare only paid for
telehealth services in rural areas very
short visits and it also required them
to have a long-standing relationship
with their provider but now with the
corona virus we're expanding telehealth
services and this is really important
for a couple of reasons number one it
helps our health care providers focus on
the most you know people that have the
most dire healthcare needs secondly it
keeps
people's safe if you're a diabetic
patient you may not even have any
symptoms you know around the coronavirus
no respiratory disease and if you come
into the office and you're sitting in
the waiting room you're having to travel
you could potentially get sick number
two for people that are showing symptoms
it's better for them to communicate with
their doctor through telehealth and that
means they're not infecting additional
people through their travel to the
doctor's office or by sitting in a
waiting room now Seema are you worried
at all about running out of medicine we
were we had a conversation as a family
my mom's a diabetic and my sister said
do you think they'll run out of insulin
I said well I don't think so because
they're making just as much as they were
before can you answer that I think
people have concerns at large about
medical supplies treatments but right
now we haven't heard that there were any
issues in terms of the insulin supply I
think more of what we're hearing is that
people are concerned about supplies to
address the corona virus and that's why
the president and the vice president met
with manufacturers yesterday about
increasing the production of certain
types of equipment ventilators other
supplies and the DoD is donating
equipment as well I'm it I'm sorry I
just said right sorry does seem I've got
a question for you you know you held up
that thing that said 15 days to slow the
spread that is so important and that's
why we're social distancing and that's
why the country for the most part is
self isolating and it's these are hard
times they're challenging times but this
lockdown of 15 days really is going to
shape the trajectory of how this disease
impacts the United States for the next
two weeks and maybe even longer that's
exactly it I mean we can we can either
be Italy or we can be South Korea and
also look at China they're really seeing
their numbers go down so it's really up
to every single American to come
together to follow these guidelines and
if we all work together we could see a
flattening of the curve and this is
really important because our health care
system would be overwhelmed if we have
the degree of infections or the rate of
infections that we've seen in Italy and
that's why the White House has put out
these recommendation
you know it's going to be difficult for
people to make these modifications but
it's important that we all work together
I'm especially younger people
Millennials
you know they may feel healthy they may
feel like if I get this virus it's not
going to be that big of a deal it's just
gonna be like the flu but the reality is
they can contribute to the spread they
may not even be showing any symptoms but
they could spread it to other people
that are more vulnerable those with
underlying health care conditions
especially the elderly in that case and
so it's important that we all do our
part seniors got to get used to
something new as we all did telemedicine
is it and you're the one who's making it
happen Seema Verma thanks so much makes
it a lot easier in my house thank you so
much Seema for all that you do yeah 15
days sounds a lot better than August so
let's hope for that let's be disciplined